Yeah,
let's go ahead and get started.
There's a lot to cover,
but I want to try to unite a lot of these disparate parts of the Bible,
the mini small books clustered here at the end that we'll be considering.
I'm going to try to unite them by elaborating certain themes as we move through
them.
Um,
but as you can see from this giant chart,
um,
there's quite a bit.
First,
let's begin with the book of Ruth.
The book of Ruth is set in the days of the judges,
right?
That's the opening line of the book tells you that this happened in the days of
the judges,
but it was certainly written later.
And whether it was post exists or preexist like is not certain.
So we're going to be asking the questions of a canonical critic,
whatever its origin.
How did this book function for Second Temple Jews?
As the story of a foreign woman who's foreign status is continually emphasized
throughout the book,
Ruth the Moabite,
Ruth the Moabite mobike tests,
um,
as a foreign woman who acts no bleed and enters the community of Israel by
choice,
this story would have stood in opposition to the negative view of foreigners,
the ban on intermarriage and the purely geological definition of Israelite
identity that was promulgated by Ezra and Nehemiah in the post exhilarate
period.
So in the story,
you have a famine in Judah and that causes a Bethlehemite man,
Ellie Mellon,
uh,
and his wife,
no,
me and their two children to leave Judah.
They're going to reside in the country of Moab where the Moabites live and their
two sons marry Moabite women,
Orpah and Ruth.
You have to consider the effect that these opening verses would have had on an
ancient Israelite listener or reader.
Moab was a hostile neighbor on Israel,
south eastern boarder,
and the Moabites were hated for their ill treatment of the Israelites when they
were traveling to the promise land.
Their lack of hospitality had already led to a prohibition of intermarriage in
the Torah itself.
So the Moabites and the ammonites are two foreign groups that are explicitly
prohibited from entering the congregation in Deuteronomy 23 and these are
lights,
low opinion of the Moabites is also expressed in genesis in the very degrading
story of moabs dissent from the incestuous relationship between lot and one of
his daughters after the fall of Saddam.
And yet here we read in the opening lines of this story,
a man from Bethlehem who travels to Moab and his two sons marry Moabite women.
And then in short order Ellie Malik and his two sons who are appropriately named
sickness and death by the way,
in Hebrew,
um,
they die.
And the Israelite widow Naomi is left now with no blood relation,
no blood male relation,
only her two Moabite daughters in law and the Omi,
we,
Billy tells the girls that they should return to their father's home.
She's poor,
she'll never be able to support them as a poor widow.
She has no further sons to give to them.
And clearly they have no legal or moral obligation or tie to Naomi.
And we'll pick up the story then in chapter one verse 11 but Naomi replied,
turn back my daughters,
why should you go with me?
Have I any more sons in my body who might be husbands for you?
Turn back my daughters.
Why am too old to be married?
And even if I thought there was hope for me,
even if I'm married tonight and I also bore sons,
should you wait for them to grow up?
Should you on their account?
Debar yourselves from marriage.
Oh No,
my daughters,
my lot is far more bitter than yours for the hand of the Lord has struck out
against me and they broke into weeping again and Orpah kissed her mother in law,
a farewell.
But Ruth Clung to her.
So she said,
see,
your sister in law has returned to her people and her gods.
Go follow your sister in law.
But Ruth replied,
do not urge me to leave you to turn back and not follow you for wherever you go.
I will go wherever you lodge.
I will lodge your people shall be my people and your God,
my God,
where you die,
I will die and there I will be buried thus and more.
May the Lord do to me if even death parts me from you.
And when Naomi saw how determined she was to go with her,
she ceased to argue with her.
And the two went on until they reached Bethlehem.
All of the names in the story are wonderfully.
Symbolic is a sickness and death is like they walk on the stage with a big sign
saying I'm in a bit part and I'm ready to die.
Or Ppas name means the back of the neck because she turns her back on on her
mother-in-law.
Uh,
as well as the wonderful story with lots of names symbolisms but by the force of
sheer conviction,
Ruth joints herself to the people of her mother in law and back in Judah.
Ruth supports her mother in law and herself by gleaning the fallen.
She leaves behind the reapers in the field because according to the pentitude,
the sheaves that fall behind the reapers must be left for the poor to collect.
You don't go back and collect them.
So Ruth gleans and she gleans in the field of a kinsmen named bars,
and he's a man of,
he's described as a man of substance and she's very diligent and she soon comes
to his attention and he's very kind for her.
He,
he looks out for her safety among the,
the rough fieldworkers he provides water for her.
He's heard of what Ruth has done for an Omi,
how she left her home and left her family to come to a people that she really
didn't know.
And he blesses her.
He says,
may the Lord reward your deeds.
May you have a full recompense from the Lord,
the God of Israel,
under whose wings you have sought refuge chapter two verse 12 and he increases
his generosity,
generosity.
He shares his meal with Ruth and gives her from the heaps of green in addition
to the gleanings that she's collecting.
So Naomi is very delighted with a reus gleanings.
They more than suffice for their needs,
but she's even more learn to please at Ruth's seems to have found favor in the
eyes of Boaz.
He's being very kind and generous and she points out,
you know,
he is among our redeeming kinsmen.
Now the term here,
the Hebrew term is go l go l means redeemer.
In fact,
in a lot of the Christian language later,
this is the word they're using when they talk about my redeemer liveth.
It's simply this word go l and the go.
Al Is a person who as the nearest relative or as a close relative,
has certain legal legal obligations to another person.
And those obligations,
the primary obligations are three to redeem the person or their property if
they've been sold to a stranger due to poverty.
So to be deemed them from debt servitude essentially.
So you're go else should do that for you to marry a childless widow might.
So if a man dies and his wife,
his child list the go,
Al is supposed to marry her,
provide seed,
and the firstborn son will be named after the man who is dead.
So he's supposed to marry a childless widow and produce offspring for the
deceased.
Usually that falls first to the brother.
And then in the case of the blood redeemer,
uh,
also the redeemer is supposed to avenge the blood of a kinsmen.
So if you are killed,
your redeemer is supposed to seek vengeance for you.
Boss is a somewhat distant relative,
but now only believes he's the answer to their dual problem of poverty on the
one hand and Ruth's widowhood on the other hand.
So in chapter three,
she urges Ruth to make a visit to boss.
He's winnowing barley on the threshing floor and Ruth is supposed to bathe
herself,
anoint herself,
um,
dress up and go out at night to the threshing floor.
Um,
you should know that in biblically threshing floor floors tend to be places of
revelry,
um,
at the end of the harvest time and they are often frequented by prostitutes.
But now me seems to be planning Ruth's seduction of boss.
She Instructs Ruth to,
uh,
not to reveal herself until blahs has finished eating and drinking.
And when he lies down,
Ruth is to approach him and uncover his feet.
This is possibly a sexual euphemism and lie down and he will tell her what she
is to do.
So Ruth follows these instructions exactly.
Chapter three verses seven to 11 boy as ate and drank and in a cheerful mood
went to lie down beside the grain pile and then she went over stealthily and
uncovered his feet and lay down.
In the middle of the night the man give a start and pulled back.
There was a woman lying at his feet.
Who are you?
He asked and she replied,
I am your handmaid,
Ruth.
Spread your robe over your handmade for you are a redeeming kinsmen ago,
AOL and he exclaimed,
be blessing of the Lord daughter,
your latest deed of loyalty is greater than the first and that you have not
turned to younger men,
whether poor or rich and now daughter have no fear.
I will do in your behalf.
Whatever you ask for.
All the elders of my town know what a fine woman you are.
So Ruth's request is that molars act as her redeemer and spread his robe over
her,
which is a a formal act of protection and a spousal and boas assures her that he
will redeem her.
He then goes on to point out however,
that there is another kinsmen who is actually a closer relation and therefore
has the first right of refusal and Boaz will settle the matter legally in the
morning.
And we're left wondering what transpired in the night.
Uh,
in chapter four we read the legal proceeding by which the other kinsmen is freed
of his obligation and his claim to Ruth.
And this then clears away,
enables bylaws to marry her.
But the punchline to the whole story is yet to come.
And that occurs in chapter four verses 13 to 17.
So Boaz married Ruth,
she became his wife and he'd cohabited with her and the Lord let her conceive
and she bore a son.
And the women said to Naomi,
bet blessed it'd be the Lord who has not withheld a redeemer from you today.
May His name be perpetuated in Israel.
He will renew your life and sustain your old age for he is born of your daughter
in law who loves you and is better to you than seven sons.
And now me took the child and held it to her bosom.
She became,
it's foster.
Mother and the women neighbors gave him a name saying a son is born to Naomi.
They named him over head.
He was the father of Jesse,
father of David.
So David God's anointed king over Israel.
David with whom God covenanted,
that his house should reign forever.
David from WHO's line would come the messianic king to rule in the final age.
[inaudible]
this David is said to be the direct descendant,
the great grandson of a foreign woman from a country of idol worshipers and a
Moabite tests no less.
So it seems that this very short and very moving story represents a strand of
thought that stood in opposition to the line of line of thinking found,
for example,
and Ezra as call for a ban on intermarriage as the only means of ensuring
faithfulness to Israel's God.
Not only is Ruth the Moabite test not guilty of abominable practices,
she's the ancestors.
If y'all always chosen monarch.
And she's praised in the story by all who know her as a paragon of crested,
this quality of,
of steadfast love and um,
Kevin dental loyalty,
um,
that binds the members of the Covenant Community to one another and to God.
Ruth the Moabite tests stood by an elderly widow to whom she had no real legal
obligation and she was accepted into the covenant community.
The acceptance of foreigners is well documented in post exit like Judaism,
despite as polemical efforts to exclude foreigners from the community,
it's important to remember that as,
as reforms never became normative for the entire community posting Zelig and
later Rabbinic Judaism never adopted the purely geological definition of Jewish
identity.
They allowed for the phenomenon of conversion and marriage into the covenant by
persons of Foreign Birth who accepted the god of Israel.
A possibility that as her completely forecloses,
as,
as extreme views were popular among sectarian groups.
So as Ryan exclusivism is champion for example,
in writings that are found at Qumran,
um,
it exerted some influence on early Christian bans on marriage,
absolute bans on marriage between believers and unbelievers.
But it's a book of Ruth that features prominently in the Jewish conversion
ceremony.
To this day
you have a different kind of acceptance of foreigners that's voiced by profits
of the restoration period.
So these are profits,
um,
fifth century and we'll look slate late sixth and fifth century.
Um,
we're going to look now briefly at some of the last prophetic books and these
are writings that dated that date to the time of the first generations of
returned exiles and on earlier profits and the pre exhilarate period,
right?
The classical profits we've already looked at,
they had spoken of a remnant that would be restored and would be restored
gloriously to its land.
But the returned exiles faced a life of great hardship,
the reality of poverty and the difficulties in rebuilding the temple and the
hostility of the Judeans who,
um,
had remained behind as well as the hostility of the surrounding peoples.
Um,
the absence of any real political independence under a Davidic king.
All of these things fell far short of the profits,
the early prophets,
glorious descriptions of this restored remnant.
And so new profits in the period of the restoration have to address the
community's disappointment.
And the short book of High Guy Contains the words of the Prophet Haggai,
um,
spoken primarily to [inaudible] is the governor of Judea and High Guy prophesies
around five 20 and he declares that all of the difficulties the community was
facing,
the agricultural setbacks and the famines,
these were all signs of God's displeasure that the temple,
um,
hadn't been completed.
As the robot Velez convinced by this,
the people return to their task enthusiastically.
And as we know,
the temple is rebuilt as high guy promised.
Um,
he says it's a humble structure,
but soon it's going to be filled with treasures flowing in from all nations and
the promises of the restoration that were made by the prophets of old or just
around the corner.
So high guy longed for a rebuilt temple,
but not only that,
also for the reestablishment of Judah's independence under a Davidic king.
And he held out hope for Zerubbabel,
the governor who was after all a descendant of David through the last king that
went into exile.
He hoped that he would serve as God's Messiah or appointed King.
That hope is even stronger in the work of high guys.
Contemporary the Prophet Zechariah,
um,
securize 14 chapters long and the first eight chapters contain the prophecies of
the historical Zechariah around five 20 or so.
The last chapters,
chapters nine through 14.
This is known as Second Zechariah.
These chapters contain obscure writings from a later hand and they are of a very
different type or genre.
They are written in the apocalyptic vein,
so we won't talk about those.
Now we'll consider momentarily.
I'm going to be talking about apocalyptic for the last half of the lecture.
So for right now I'm interested,
however,
in the first eight chapters which represent the oracles of the historical
Prophet Zechariah,
around five 20,
you preached and prophesied for about two years.
He urges in these chapters,
the rebuilding of the temple.
The first six chapters contain a series of elaborate and symbolic visions,
eight different visions that are revealed by an angel or a divine messenger.
That's a mode of revelation that's going to be standard in apocalyptic
literature.
As we'll soon see,
um,
earlier prophets received a word or a vision,
but,
uh,
as we move towards apocalyptic literature and later literature,
profits often receive messages from God through an angel or a messenger.
Um,
these visions,
uh,
focus hope on Zerubbabel,
the governor and on the priest Joshua the high priest Joshua.
And the idea is that they'll rule in a kind of Dye Archi as monarch and priest
at the same,
at some point,
however,
it seems that the Persians got rid of his Aruba Vail.
He was ousted perhaps because a messianic hope was starting to gather around
Zerubbabel.
So Zechariah's prophecy seem to be adjusted to refer solely to Joshua,
although they originally referred to Zerubbabel.
And although chapter six in particular,
it seems to refer originally to Zerubbabel,
it is altered so that it now depicts Joshua as a shoot or a branch from Jessie's
stock.
Jesse stock meaning a David died.
David's father was Jesse.
So to say,
a route from Jesse stuck is to say,
uh,
David died.
It says that Joshua will rebuild the sanctuary.
He will wear the royal insignia,
although he is the priest.
So the elevation,
however,
of the high priest in,
um,
is a feature of the post exhilarate period.
It's a feature of Judah in the post exhilarate period.
High priest coming to take some of the,
um,
the trappings of royal office chapters seven and eight.
Declare God's promise to turn and to do good things in Jerusalem and the house
of Judah.
So long as the people will turn from they're unjust and evil ways.
And Zechariah points forward to the Glorious Day when all the nations of the
world will eagerly come to seek the Lord in Jerusalem and to entreat his favor.
So we read in Zechariah eight 23,
thus said the Lord of hosts.
In those days,
10 men from nations of every tongue will take hold.
They will,
each team,
they will take hold of every Jew by a corner of his cloak and say,
let us go with you.
For we have heard that God is with you.
And thus a this restoration period,
you can see,
um,
features,
profits.
Who envisions other nations joining Israel in the worship of Yahweh?
They will come to rally around and join Israel in the worship of God in
Jerusalem.
The last wave of prophetic writings that we have addresses the disappointment
and the disillusionment of the late sixth and fifth century Judeans.
What was the message of these writings?
The basic message was that the earlier profits there promises of future glory
for the restored remnant.
Um,
these were all true.
The future just isn't.
Now,
it's only going to happen in the Eschaton.
The final day.
Only then will the glory of Jerusalem and a messianic ruler be restored.
And the hope that has to sustain the community through the bleak present is
therefore an eschatological hope,
a hope that focuses on an ideal account of the end eschatology and account of
the end.
Because in the end of days,
everything will be set right.
So as we move later into the period,
we find increasingly,
um,
the hope for the community is thrust off into the future in an eschatology.
Parts of third,
Isaiah,
um,
depict the bitter reality of life in Postig,
Zelig,
Judah,
and advanced and eschatology.
You remembered the book of Isaiah,
which is 66 chapters.
We divide into three parts,
one through 39 which is the historical Isaiah.
Then we have second Isaiah and then third Isaiah we're dealing with now that's
chapters 56 to 66 the anonymous prophetic author of these chapters denounces the
failings of the exiles but does hold out and eschatology a doctrine of final
things that depicts what's going to happen in the end of days.
This kind of eschatology differs from the depiction of Zions future glory that
we had in the early classical profits.
The earlier prophetic pronouncements generally referred to a re reestablishment
of Judas fortunes in historical time,
but eschatological works like third.
Isaiah look beyond historical time.
They're looking to a time of a new heaven and a new earth.
When Judah's sins will be forgotten,
the land will become an earthly paradise transformed and blessed with peace and
prosperity and length of days.
This is from Isaiah 65 verses 17 to 25 for behold,
I am creating a new heaven and a new earth.
The former things shall not be remembered.
They shall never come to mind.
Be Glad then and rejoice forever in what I am creating for I shall create
Jerusalem as a joy and her people as a delight.
Never again shall there be heard shall be heard there the sounds of weeping and
wailing.
No more shall there be an infant or gray beard who does not live out his days.
He who dies at a 100 years shall be wrecking to youth and he who fails to reach
a hundred shall be reckoned.
A cursed for the days of my people shall be as long as the days of the tree.
My chosen ones shall outlive the work of their hands.
They shall not toil to no purpose.
They shall not bear children for terror,
but they shall be a people blessed by the Lord and their offspring shall remain
with them before they pray.
I will answer while they are still speaking,
I will respond,
but wolf and the lamb shall graze together and the lion shall eat straw like the
ox and the serpents.
Food shall be earth in all my sacred mount.
Nothing evil or vial shall be done,
said the Lord.
See this interesting notion of a completely new transformed heaven and earth.
The lion is vegetarian.
Again,
the serpent,
no longer is,
is,
there's not this animosity between the serpent and humans as was decreed at the
end of genesis with the curse on the snare serpent.
They're going to just be eating earth.
Um,
and there will be no,
no danger.
Third,
Isaiah also sounds this theme of Openness,
um,
reassuring foreigners and Unix who have joined themselves to y'all way that
there'll be welcomed in the holy temple to serve God and to offer sacrifices.
Now,
this is significant.
Again,
remember that Deuteronomy 23,
right in the heart of the pentitude bands,
Unix specifically and certain foreigners,
Moabites ammonites,
uh,
from entering the congregation.
Remember also that [inaudible] explicitly excluded foreigners from the restored
temple in his visions at the end of the book.
Um,
and this is also clearly the policy of Ezra and Nehemiah.
They had,
um,
an ammonite who had,
uh,
his,
lodgings or office or room in the temple.
They had him thrown out of,
of that area in the temple.
But third,
Isaiah seems to oppose such restrictions.
Isaiah 56 verses three to seven,
let not the foreigner say who has attached himself to the Lord.
The Lord will keep me apart from his people and let not the eunuch say I'm a
withered tree,
for thus said the Lord.
As for the Eunuchs who keep my sabbath,
who have chosen what I desire and hold fast to my covenant,
I will give them in my house and within my walls,
a monument and a name better than sons or daughters.
I will give them an everlasting name,
which shall not perish.
As for the foreigners who attach themselves to the Lord,
to Minister to him and to love the name of the Lord,
to be his servants,
all who keep the sabbath and do not profane it,
and who hold fast to my covenant,
I will bring them to my sacred mountain.
Let them rejoice in my house of prayer.
Their burnt offerings and sacrifices will be,
shall be welcome on my altar for my house shall be called a house of prayer for
all peoples.
So on this issue,
clearly the post exhibit community was quite divided
and there's only one,
um,
biblical book,
which pretty much in its entirety belongs to a genre of literature,
a known as apocalyptic,
and that in its entirely entirety,
but it is the most significant and thorough going apocalyptic book in the Bible.
The term apocalyptic derives from the Greek word apokalypsis.
Um,
and apokalypsis is a revealing,
all right?
So something that's apocalyptic is a revealing apocalypse is a revelation of
things to come.
And as apocalypses generally predict the end of historical time and the
beginning of a new world order,
they are generally concerned with eschatology.
So apocalyptic works tend to be eschatological.
All right?
That doesn't mean all eschatological work is apocalyptic apocalyptic literature
within the Bible.
And then much more significantly outside of the Hebrew Bible is characterized by
certain,
um,
distinguishing features which I've thrown up in,
in brief note form over here.
All right?
So apocalyptic literature is always eschatological deals with the in time.
But to be apocalyptic or work has to have certain kinds of,
uh,
features.
And not all this fatalities have these features.
This is what they are.
Most apocalyptic writings are pseudonymous.
They're generally attributed to important figures of the past,
right?
He,
doc or Abraham or someone,
they tend to also feature a revelation by a heavenly messenger,
an angel who comes in a vision or a dream to deliver some sort of message.
In general,
the message is highly symbolic.
It's coated,
and often the symbolism is quite bizarre.
You'll have surreal images of beasts and monsters and usually these depict
foreign nations.
The visions tend to be chronological.
They tend to be a systematic chronology of,
um,
past,
present,
and future events that represent the march of history in coded form again,
and so it tends to require interpretation.
And that's usually given by the divine messenger who reveals the symbolic
chronological code.
A fourthly apocalypses tend to predict a series of catastrophes.
These are signs of the coming of the end,
right?
That that final point in the march of history that's being laid out.
You have motifs from ancient myths very often used to describe these
catastrophes.
I'll come back to that in a minute.
A Po.
Apocalypse is also tend to be what I call morally dualistic.
They tend to divide humankind into two mutually exclusive groups.
The righteous,
which is always a tiny minority and the wicked,
which is always the vast majority.
Um,
and there's going to be some final public judgment and the righteous will be
saved and the wicked will be destroyed in this respect,
especially later apocalypses show the influence of Persian thought.
Persian thought is also quite dualist in nature with oppositions of light and
darkness or good and evil and light and death and so on.
So there does seem to be some Persian influence.
And of course we were well into the Persian period at this point.
Um,
six feature is that God generally appears and apocalyptic literature as an
enthroned king.
He brings all of history to a crashing end and demonstrates his sovereignty.
He confounds the wicked,
he does all the things things at the same time,
you know,
he confounds the wicked and establishes himself as the sovereign and and throne
King in control.
Seventh apocalyptic literature,
as I briefly mentioned before,
often incorporates mythological motifs and imagery,
especially the Motif of a battle between God and primordial chaotic elements.
And that will often be,
um,
the imagery that's used in depicting the final battle with the godless are the
wicked apocalypse is also generally depict a judgment of the individual dead,
um,
followed by everlasting life or punishment.
So again,
apocalypse has developed quite substantially outside the writings of the Hebrew
Bible.
In the Bible,
we have a few scattered apocalyptic elements and then much of the book of
Daniel.
Um,
and so we,
we don't see the idea of life after death really in the Hebrew Bible until this
very late apocalyptic book of Daniel.
The idea is very influential in the Dead Sea Scrolls.
They are very dualist.
Um,
and in the writings of the New Testament,
of course,
so our belief in personal immortality,
it belief in a general resurrection of the dead.
These arise from a negative view of this world as a place where justice can be
obtained.
So apocalyptic writers examine the world they lived in and they drew the
conclusion that reward and punishment,
we're going to be made in an afterlife.
They were certainly not doled out in this life as Israel suffered.
And this is a marked break from the general conviction of the Hebrew Bible,
that human life is limited to this world and that the fundamental concern of
humans and God is morality in this life and not in mortality.
In another.
You think apocalyptic literature can be described as a literature of hope and
despair.
It's a literature of despair or pessimism because it's basic premise is that
this world holds out no promise for the righteous.
Um,
it's a literature of hope or optimism because it affirms that God will
intervene,
he will intervene in human history.
He'll set everything right.
He'll interrupt the natural order.
He's going to destroy this broken world as we know it,
and he'll do soar.
Do so in order to rescue the righteous and humiliate the wicked.
And if you've already died,
don't worry,
there'll be a resurrection.
It will all be made right?
But this hope for supreme and ultimate vindication is thrust off into the
future.
So apocalyptic constitutes yet one more response to the traumatic events,
the crises,
and the disappointments of Israel's history.
Um,
in a second we'll get to Daniel,
but there are a few,
I'm apocalyptic passages of varying lengths in other post exhilarate books.
I'll just touch on them very quickly.
Second,
a second,
Zechariah and a little bit,
uh,
the book of Joe Just to prepare us for Daniel.
So Second Zechariah.
Now these are chapters nine through 14.
We talked about the historical Zechariah chapters one through eight.
So this is second Zechariah chapters nine through 14.
And it's a collection of diverse Oracle's probably fifth century or later that
contain these strange visions and predictions.
Um,
their meanings cannot always be fathomed,
but they seem to focus on the day of the Lord and the restoration of Jerusalem
and the rise of a new and humble king who will reign and piece over a new world
order.
Chapter 14 is a vision of this global battle that will bring history to an end.
Um,
God's going to bring all the nations to Jerusalem where they will plunder the
city.
They will kill almost all of the inhabitants.
And then at the last moment when things look the most desperate,
God will intervene and he'll fight for Israel and exact revenge on her enemies.
And it's after this final battle that God will transform the earth into a
paradise.
So Israel's enemies will rage against one another.
The surviving nations will pilgrimage to Jerusalem again.
Jerusalem now is elevated above all cities.
Um,
and these nations will come to Jerusalem to worship your way at his temple.
And yeah,
we'll be sovereign over the world.
Joel,
very short little book.
Um,
probably the latest prophetic book.
it also contains apocalyptic material.
The versification of Joel is a v varies tremendously in different English
translations.
So I'm using the verse markings that are in the Bible you have,
but if you consult another Bible,
some of them have only three chapters,
some have four.
It can be confusing.
Well,
we can divide Joel into two parts,
up to chapter two,
verse 27.
So that's the first part from one,
one to two 27 or one to really,
and that contains a description of a military invasion.
It's symbolized by an army of locusts and this invasion,
this,
this army of locus is interpreted as a divine punishment that is necessary or
that must come before the day of the Lord.
The second part of Joel,
which begins in Verse 28 of chapter two is a fully apocalyptic,
um,
description of the,
the,
the final day of terror reading from chapter three verses three and four before
the great and terrible day of the Lord comes,
I will set portents in the sky and on earth,
blood and fire and pillars of smoke.
The Sun will be turned to darkness and the moon to blood before the great and
terrible day of the Lord comes,
but the righteous are going to survive.
This is pointed out in chapter three,
verse five but everyone who invokes the name of the Lord shall escape for the
Sh,
there shall be a remnant on Mount Zion and in Jerusalem as the Lord promised.
As we move into chapter four of Joel,
the day of the Lord is envisaged as a judgment day for all peoples,
right?
So this is increasingly the view of the Eschaton,
a final battle,
and also a judgment day.
And that Judgment Day will then issue in a new age.
This is an idea that the book of Daniel we'll elaborate on in a minute,
not to mention the apocalyptic writings that are outside of the Hebrew Bible.
In this Judgment Day,
God will summon all of the godless nations to the Valley of Judgment.
Jehoshaphat's which means God will judge.
So the Valley of Jehoshaphat and here,
the final battle between good and evil will take place.
And after that,
God's people will be blessed and the holy city will never again suffer shame for
low in those days.
And in that time when I restore the fortunes of Judah and Jerusalem,
I will gather all the nations and bring them down to the valley of Jehoshaphat.
And there I will contend with them over my very own people,
Israel,
which they scattered among the nations.
Towards the end then of the book we read,
let the nations rouse themselves and March up to the valley of Jehoshaphat.
For there,
I will sit in judgment over all the nations.
Roundabout swing.
The sickle for the crop is ripe.
Come and tread for the wine presses full.
The vats are overflowing for great as their wickedness,
but the Lord will be a shelter to his people of refuge to the children of
Israel.
And Jerusalem shall be holy nevermore shall strangers pass through it.
And in that day,
the mountains Sheldrick with wine,
the hills shall flow with milk and all the water courses of Judah shall flow
with water,
uh,
spring shell issue from the House of the Lord and shall water the Wadi of a
Casey as and Judah shall be inhabited forever.
And Jerusalem.
Throughout the ages,
we see a lot of eschatological features.
In the book of Joel,
you have first of all,
a series of disasters,
a signal,
the impending wrath of God.
You have a cosmic battle in which y'all way triumphs over Israel's enemy.
Um,
and we've seen in apocalyptic literature in general,
a facilely equation of the righteous.
And the wicked with Israel and F and other nations.
Um,
and then also we have this outpouring of blessings on God's people,
city and land.
And finally,
God's continued protection and presence and nations who are not Israel's
enemies,
uh,
join in the worship of God.
And that final time,
again,
note the important difference between classical prophecy and the apocalyptic
literature.
Both of them speak about final things.
Both of them speak about an end time,
but the classical prophets did not in general expect that the course of human
affairs would come to an end,
right?
Only that Israel's rebellion would end or that Israel would live under a perfect
king,
anointed by God in the apocalyptic imagination.
History itself is a closed process.
It will end and then a new age,
a new world order would begin in the present age and the new age or
qualitatively distinct,
the present age is under the dominion of evil powers.
We see it particularly in the apocalyptic writings outside of the Bible and in
the New Testament that that power that has dominion over the present age is
Satan.
Satan is the arch enemy of God.
All right?
The age to come will be free of all,
more evil,
moral corruption and death.
Satan will be defeated,
but God himself is the one who has to do this.
God must intervene to bring the present age to a crashing halt and initiate this
new world order.
So let's turn now to Daniel for a full apocalyptic work.
Um,
Daniel also can be divided really into two parts.
And the first six chapters,
um,
have often been described as heroic fiction.
They're a bit like the book of Esther that we'll be talking about on Wednesday.
Um,
just a,
a good story.
Um,
Esther's particularly has a lot of irony and is very,
very funny,
but like the book of Esther,
Daniel Features a Jew who lives in a gentile court and he's saved from disaster.
And I've listed the kings who are discussed in the book of Daniel.
I'm these chapters tell of Daniel's adventures under back to Babylonian kings
notebook had nets are,
and Belshazzar,
that's the text says to Babylonian Kings in a book or nets or in Belshazzar,
a Medean King Darrius who happens to be unknown to history.
Um,
Persian King Cyrus,
that's a whole lot of years.
Um,
and the historical inaccuracy of the work,
right?
You have the chronology of more than a century being telescoped here.
Um,
there's other inaccuracies.
Belshazzar was actually never a king.
He was sort of a prince regent.
Um,
he was defeated by Cyrus,
not by Darrius.
So they're,
they're tremendous historical inaccuracy.
And this is a sign that this was written at a much later time.
Looking back when the history of the period 300 years ago was very confused.
Um,
there's no clear historical knowledge of this Persian period,
Babylonian and Persian period.
Um,
and so the book we,
we know was written quite late,
um,
perhaps the end of the third century,
those first six chapters,
we have a better idea about the remainder of the book.
Chapters seven through 12 are fully apocalyptic in genre,
and they were composed between one 67 and one 64.
I don't know if I wrote that up there.
Yeah.
One 67 and one 64 BCE.
This was a time when Jews were suffering intense persecution at the hands of the
solution.
King of Syria.
Antiochus Epiphanes Antioch is the fourth.
Um,
and so Daniel is the latest book of the Hebrew Bible,
right?
It was,
it was chronologically the latest book written between one 67,
one 64 BCE.
But the author writes in code,
he writes and code so that,
you know,
some hostile person would not be able to understand,
right?
The author disguises his references to contemporary historical events and
personalities in these visions,
these symbolic visions,
uh,
that are attributed to a remote era of the past.
Right.
Let's go back and look at the contents of these two sections in chapters one
through six.
Daniel is represented as a loyal Jew who's living in the exile and Babylonia,
right?
Sixth Century exhilarate period among idol worshipers.
Um,
he refuses to bow down to any other God.
He observes the dietary laws and he prays facing Jerusalem.
He seems to occupy,
occupy a position of some honor in the court.
He has the power to interpret dreams and to predict the future.
Um,
and although he's severely tested,
he remains true to your way and Yahweh aids him.
And more than one miraculous escape from danger.
The main themes of this first section,
the book of Daniel.
Um,
our Daniel's interpretations of the dreams of,
of these kings.
I'm new book had Ned Sir and,
and his,
uh,
allegiance to his God.
In chapter two,
Nebuchadnezzar has a dream of a huge statue.
It has a head of gold,
has a torso and arms of silver,
the belly and the thighs of bronze,
the legs of iron and the feet are of mixed iron and clay.
I've kind of given you a little grid and in a minute we're going to have
another,
um,
symbolic dream that's gonna use animals to represent the same things that are
being represented here by the metals.
So you had this statue with these metal and iron and clay feet.
Then a great stone that's uncut by human hands,
flies from heaven and smashes the clay feet of the statue and the statue
crumbles.
And this stone becomes a mountain that fills all the earth.
Daniel decodes the dreams symbolism.
And it's a historical symbolism.
The march of history.
Each metal represents a kingdom that ruled the ancient near east.
Daniel only explicitly mentions gold as Babylon,
but we can figure out the rest.
Um,
silver is Medea,
bronze is Persia,
and iron is Alexander's Grease,
right?
Macedonia and Greece that conquered the ancient Near East in the three thirties
and brought Hellenism and,
and introduce the Hellenistic period into ancient near eastern history.
After Alexander's death,
his empire was divided into smaller Hellenistic Kingdoms,
right?
The ones of greatest relevance to us,
our Ptolemaic Egypt,
and saluted Syria.
Because as you can imagine,
Palestine is caught between those two great powers.
So it's going to be fought over by those two great powers.
So you have Egypt ruled by the Telemis.
You have Syria rule by the solutions.
They're wrangling for control of the land of Israel,
that that's lying between them.
So the iron and clay feet of the statue in Daniel's dream represent these lesser
Hellenistic kingdoms of Egypt and Syria that succeeded Alexander's Empire in our
mix of Hellenistic and,
and eastern elements.
The stone from heaven represents the future Kingdom of God.
It's going to come and destroy these godless kingdoms and fill all of the earth
forever.
Chapter three tells the story of Daniel's three companions who refuse to worship
a giant gold statue and they get themselves thrown into a fiery furnace.
When they emerge unscathed,
the king is greatly impressed.
And so he acknowledges the God of Israel.
In chapter four,
there's a second dream.
Um,
it's interpreted by Daniel as a sign that in a book had Ned sir will be struck
down seven times.
He's going to lose his reason.
He's going to lose his throne until he realizes that God is the source of all
divine and human power.
And when this in fact comes to pass and look,
Nebuchadnezzar's seems to suffer the fit of insanity that drives him from
society.
The king then praises the God most high as the king.
In chapter five,
Daniel's enemies at court trick the Medean King.
Now Daria,
so we're moving to different kings.
Um,
they trick him into issuing an edict against those who pray to anyone.
But the king,
uh,
this is a problem for Daniel.
Daniel violates the edict of course,
and he's arrested and he's thrown into a den of lions.
But he emerges unharmed and the result is again,
that the foreign king in this case,
Dari is now recognized as the supremacy.
If Galloway and orders all in his kingdom and his kingdom to revere the Jewish
God.
There is of course no historical merit to these stories of Babylonian and
Persian kings acknowledging or adopting the god of the Jews who lived in exile
among them.
These stories seem to give voice to the hope or the fantasy that accrual and
impious monarch might be taught humility by Yahweh.
They also provide a model for life in the diaspora.
Jews can live in the gentile world,
but they must never forget God and his laws.
And then we move into the second half of the book of Daniel Chapters seven to
12.
This.
Um,
as we move into this part of Daniel,
we switch from the third person into the first person.
So Daniel Seven to 12 was written in the first person and it's fully
apocalyptic.
And here.
Daniel has a series of visions and dreams that are interpreted for him by an
angel.
And again,
that's a classic feature of the apocalyptic genre.
And these,
uh,
these visions again survey ancient near eastern history from the sixth to the
second centuries.
Chapter Seven,
again represents the succession of kingdoms,
the Babylonian,
the Medea,
and the Persian,
the Macedonian empires.
But this time as beasts.
So you have a lion,
a bear,
a winged leopard,
and an ogre.
The ogre has horns and the horns of this ogre then represent these two lesser
Hellenistic kingdoms,
the Ptolemies of Egypt and the solutions of Syria.
The boastful little horn is the Syrian king.
Antioch is Epiphany's himself in a second vision.
The ancient of days.
This is the term that's used.
It seems to be God in a white robe and a beard seated on a fiery chariot throne.
But the ancient of days confers glory and kingship on one like a son of man.
Now in Daniel,
this phrase,
the son of man,
which generally means mortal,
uh,
um,
as opposed to divine in the Bible.
But in Daniel,
the phrase seems to refer to a figure that's in human form,
but more than a human,
probably an angel like Michael or Gabriel.
Both of them are represented as leaders against the forces of Persia and Greece.
And this figure establishes as everlasting kingdom to replace the Beastie all
kingdoms that have preceded it.
So the son of man overwhelms the little horn and to focus who is said to be
making war on saints.
That's a code for loyal Jews who says to who is said to have been trying to
change their law and abolish their religion.
And we know that these were parts of the persecution in one 67 to one 64 by
Antiochus.
Um,
he,
you know,
he tried to stop a worship in the sanctuary and so on in a third vision then the
horn that represents Antioch as is said,
to trample the land of splendor Israel to challenge the Army of Heaven to remove
the perpetual sacrifice.
Antioch is,
did halt the sacrifice,
the sacrificial service in the temple,
and to set up an abomination of desolation on the sacrificial altar.
And we know that Antioch is set up some kind of pagan altar on the sacrificial
altar in the temple in Jerusalem and erected a statue of Zeus in the sanctuary.
So this depiction of the persecution under Antioch,
this is presented here,
but it's presented in veiled form for reasons of safety.
In chapter nine we have a moving prayer for deliverance and the Angel Gabriel
assures Daniel that the end is near and that the end was even predicted by
Jeremiah who had said that Jerusalem would lie desolate 70 years.
You will recall now,
Jeremiah prophesied,
I'm going to do some math now.
So this is dangerous.
Jeremiah prophesied in the early sixth century and the chapters of Daniel we'll
written many centuries later.
Someone can figure it out in the one sixties so was Jeremiah prophesied falsely
when he said that God would deliver Israel from her enemies and establish a
kingdom of Judah and 70 years?
No,
not according to the book of Daniel because in the book of Daniel it said that
Jeremiah also was speaking in a code.
Jeremiah meant the 70 weeks of years,
which is to say 490 years would pass before the consummation of all things.
And the last week was the reign of Antioch Ihss Epiphany's.
We are in the last week of these years now.
So the writer's maintaining that he's living in the last days and the final
moments of the last week of years.
And this is very typical of apocalyptic literature.
The time is at hand.
We are in the final stages,
is now all the birth pangs of the Messiah,
these terrible things that are being visited upon us.
And God is soon going to win victory through a mighty act and introduced the
messianic age ending Israel's long years of desolation,
uh,
of desolation.
So apocalyptic literature sees history as determined.
It's a closed drama that must be played out.
I'm requiring no action on the part of humans except faithful waiting.
God's kingdom will come solely by God's power,
but it has to be proceeded by this time of trouble.
These troubles are nothing but the birth pangs of the Messianic Age and the
faithful whose names are recorded in God's book will be rescued.
Chapter 1212 imagines a resurrection of the dead as a compensation to those who
died under the of Antioch.
This,
it's a clear attempt to deal with the injustice that Mars,
this world,
and it's the only passage of the Bible to explicitly espouse the idea of an
individual life after death.
And as I say,
breaks with a longer Israelite tradition that's vague or silent on this issue.
Not all Jews accepted the idea,
but it would be essential to the rise of Christianity,
which is deeply indebted to apocalyptic thinking.
And through Christianity it came to have a very far reaching impact on Western
civilization.
The book of Daniel is a response to specific historical circumstances.
It's a response to the crisis of persecution and martyrdom that was going on in
the second century.
That was a new kind of crisis that led to a new kind of response.
Because the earlier crises of seven 22 and five 86 they could be explained as
punishment for sin and faithlessness.
But now in the second century,
Jews were dying,
not because they were faithless,
but precisely because they were faithful,
because they refused to obey the decrees of Antioch Ihss and to violate their
law and covenant,
and they were dying.
So this new phenomenon of martyrdom really for the first time required new
responses.
And the book of Daniel provides a fully apocalyptic response.
Remain Faithful.
Wait,
Daniel urges.
Know that this will all be set right by God,
not in this world,
but in an ultimate and cataclysmic triumph of life and death,
life over life and faith over death and evil.
And it will be soon.
And God,
Daniel emphasizes God's from control of history.
And so bull bolsters loyal Jews who are suffering indignities and torture and
even death all around him because of their faith.
So we've seen the zealous fifth century,
fifth century response of Ezra and Nehemiah to the fateful events of Israel's
history.
They believed as Israel's rededication to God and the covenant involved as a
first step,
cessation of intimate relations with foreigners,
separation from their abominable practices.
We've seen very different views that would integrate foreigners in the worship
of Yahweh way.
We've seen also the later emergence of apocalyptic as an expression of present
despair and future hope that entailed the divinely orchestrated and cataclysmic
defeat of the wicked enemies who persecuted Israel.
And in the last lecture,
we're going to look at two books of the Hebrew Bible that take very different
approaches.
The book of Esther and the book of Jonah.